[Music]
Oh [ __ ] broke oh ok ok I gave up ok ok
I got tired ok I asked a question on
citizens of Joe Mallya right I was like
guys we're gonna we're basically gonna
film last minute we need your help
give us some topics give them give us
some like feedback what do you want to
know and one really stood out and the
question was what would you tell your 20
year old self and this is like you know
why it stood out because I forgot I was
30 wait I'm not 20 that's crazy what did
you think you were older a younger well
just for a split second I was like what
would I tell my 20 year old self I am 20
wow I thought I was in my 20s good for
you man I don't know if that's really
exactly trying to be positive yeah I
guess I'd be positive what I what I
realized is like okay we got like 10
years on our fans sometimes right if
they're if most of them are in their 20s
I'm assuming and Mike answers that I had
for them are different like back in a
day they asked the same questions should
I go to college is it worth it what
should i do should I choose my dream job
or should i do what's more realistic or
whatever like those questions are still
the same because they're all in the same
life stage when you're in your 20s right
and then my question of my answers has
evolved over the years with my age but
also I forget that I'm growing so I
don't know this question was
mind-blowing to me and I just wanted to
hear your guys thoughts on that Julia
you just left your 20s how do you feel
because you're like no baby in my mind
like you're like the little sister I
feel like I'm on the same boat with you
where I still feel like I'm in my 20s
right stop aid for yours make sense did
you literally just like this has been
out of it for 10 you 5 years do they
just have such good genes
you don't look none of you guys look
guys old you are oh I just felt like I
stopped aging at 25 oh that's what I
felt like that's why I still feel like
you still look like the same damn little
girl that came in here Thanks like I
really don't know the difference really
except for these rooms I'm just kidding
right I have Y friends who are like 21
22 they look like they're 40 it's crazy
he was like 16 you look like a 40 year
old man when he was 15 yeah look 40
because of wrinkles and [ __ ] you just
have like like like like prominent
feature oh cool you don't look old but
you look old got it look like a [ __ ]
grown man Walter the beard helps a lot
well I can't shave the beard I feel like
suppose I look older why the [ __ ] did he
get he did not get carded at 19 and I
got carded at like 29 and xem still
carded same all the time I'm always
carded I'm always hoping that they card
me this helps so getting married helps
with not being carted as much because
they tilt they'll take notice and they'd
be like okay I guess he's fat when t1 I
guess aside from you know us being
[ __ ] [ __ ] aside from us aging
gracefully what would you tell your 20
year old self because I was a [ __ ]
loser at 20 completely specifically 20
or 20s throughout early twenties I think
this question is really you in your 20s
I don't think you were a loser I was a
pretty big [ __ ] loser I would say so
I met you when you were in your 20s and
I feel like you had a pretty good
direction in terms of where you wanted
ahead to which is rewind a lot of other
people you know I feel like a lot of
people are aimless in their 20s from
people I've met over the years now I
would say that well I think that I
I know that I could have been successful
earlier but I had a hard time believing
in my own thoughts and also staying
disciplined to what I really wanted
yeah that was my thing I think I would
tell my 20 my in my 20s self is to try
to be fearless because I feel like those
were scary
yeah there's a lot of moments in my life
where I felt like I was kind of scared
to try to do something can we specify
what you mean specifically it's like oh
by specifically yeah cause it's like
like I don't want to be afraid to like
go skydiving or like I don't want to be
afraid to like like I don't know I think
for me it was um I guess in terms of of
a college life I don't think I lived up
to it very much because I think I was
more on like that one-track mind words
like I just want to be in and out of
college I didn't I didn't really want to
experience it right and I think because
I was so hold into that mindset that if
someone were to invite me to a party
whatever I would feel way out of my
element and be like no it's okay I'll
just pass I'm just gonna stay at home
not gonna do that
you regret not being a bigger hole gonna
say about myself yes every car not
[ __ ] more responsibly you you you
thought that that's what you should have
done cuz you're early
you were like a saint uh you're lost
your virginity later live you were like
super I don't know if I think I just had
a lot of like the traditional like guilt
yeah the kill and just that stigma where
now I would tell myself girl it's okay
let the titties loose like just a little
bit
yeah like experiment like like like get
with girls get with thighs like just
yeah I think that comes ibly yeah I
think that comes with age cuz I feel
that I feel the same way too in the fact
that you want to be a home I yeah when I
was younger after I had a lot more
opportunities to have fight like what do
you think held you back back then was it
a shame to or yo shame it was kind of
like I was taboo so I sleep around too
much even if for guys I feel like if you
feel pressure of like of like it's much
less than what
slut-shaming or whatever buzz the guy
you still feel like you don't want to be
that do that like that guy girls and
then like and like you know one-night
stands and leaves you know and like you
want to be kind of responsible to and
like a gentleman or whatever you know
but then at the end of the day like if
if rich is having fun and if it's like
mutual like fun for your partner like
then why not like they're literally you
have like rejected sex before you know
and I'm like man like I took everything
that I could get that's tight
that's tight and that's a regret of mine
yeah for me I wish I understood
connected sex better mmm it was all
physical for me true I'm just [ __ ]
it's all I want because it's it's
literally like it's sometimes I was in
the moment and I'm all like I rather
jackoff right now it's not that good I
do that so much jack off like you're
[ __ ] and you're like I rather be jack
it off right both parts where it's like
like I would help a girl and then I'll I
go jack off like I know she's coming
tonight Oh jack off and I'm like why the
[ __ ] did I hit her up you Jack ha and
then you came and she's coming over to
get some D and you're like I'm not horny
no more yeah yeah why would you jack off
first cuz you were just that horny or
you were just like I want to last long
no no no matter what it's fine but I
think it's one it's either I'm horny or
it's also that postnup clarity we're
like I don't want to I really want her
to add it's like was it just now I gotta
like either take this girl out we gotta
hang out she has to sleep over I took a
whole night that way saying you know
what I don't really want it just done
with it yeah it's like five minutes and
then you're done and then you don't need
that urge but then otherwise it's like I
feel like I want that more connection
because and I'm like why am I doing this
when I actually have them over here like
I don't really like them I feel like
they're starting to like me and then I'm
like I'll [ __ ] and that ends up bad
because I feel like I can like just dump
them and like leave you heart breaker
that sounds like do it how many like
people that they feel like I'm an
[ __ ] I'm like no I just don't like
you
[Laughter]
that's why I don't tell them that but
it's more like how you say like I did
you say actually you're you're a guy
cheese dude
I guess so now you're you getting them
all worked up can you imagine dudes or
shaving their legs getting [ __ ] ready
for you on the opposite side that's like
if I clean my house got all this [ __ ]
ready and shave my nuts
she comes over and she wants to talk
about feelings and [ __ ] okay I love this
knew what to say action yeah talk about
feelings but just like I thought we were
gonna [ __ ] you know that is just a bait
and switch like how are you gonna show
me a titty and get all get me always
weird you come over and we're just like
having long conversations and I'm like
did I [ __ ] up here if I actually like
them and they come over
even we if you want to it's just
difficult to talk about deep issues when
I need to come like afterwards like the
clarity right it's like yeah cuz it's
like the mixed message part right like
it's like hey you send me a video of
masturbating and then like you're coming
over I'm thinking we're gonna [ __ ] and
then we're talking about some deep ass
[ __ ] and I'm standing here with a boner
and I don't want to think about sad [ __ ]
with a boner how do you get out of that
you just have to listen and let this
hasn't happened in a long time I'm just
saying like my early days of this
experience like for I don't know maybe I
don't know but then I know you're
talking about about the clarity thing
right it's like you got to come and then
your mind is clear and you're like
alright girl
let's get down to it you want to
gentlemen use the bathroom check off
come back to the conversation I think
you're right you're good but I think the
order of events should just kind of
switch up a little bit so instead of
asking them to come over and then
jacking off I think you should check off
first and then yeah don't work a mop
it's also it's not like at the late
nights it's like Oh like let's kick you
tomorrow or like let's come over tonight
we're talking earlier I don't like
cancel like last night when they're
about to leave it's more like awesome
that like working up or whatever like I
bet you they want you more now so the
thing was I feel like I got like that
because I was so like self-conscious
about like me being able to talk to
girls like who so your shyness worked
for you my shyness before it did it but
now it's like it's actually showing me
that like oh like I feel like the less
I'm show interest the more they want me
which is it's true it's weird yeah
the more you thirst the more they run
away from it it's not really weird
because we're so used to so much [ __ ]
stimulus that it's just like when the
guy is not doing that you're just like
oh wait that's cool he's actually into
me it seems like yeah I like direct
girls too
I like to be wanted because it's like
feels nice to be a hot girl from time to
time like if it's if they're direct and
I know what they want and it's just that
then it's fine but if it's like I can
start seeing that they they start
putting out their feelings and I don't
really like them and then I'm like okay
now I got to take you I'll go through
this whole process and like all this
stuff just to have sex and I don't want
that you know it's funny
they probably asked this question
wondering what we would say advice wise
where it's like you don't want you just
kind of [ __ ] follow your dreams and
[ __ ] no yeah you got a pop bar there
you're 20 you're right don't take life
so damn seriously yeah but [ __ ]
responsibly and I'm not even telling you
I'm not oh no no they might go out and
catch some disease and oh
Hey Joe told me to [ __ ] beer Oh No
get tested use protection use condoms
make sure to be upfront before you [ __ ]
like make sure they don't want more just
be like eh I just transferred and also
save your money save your money and you
know what life just gets busier and more
stressful and you think life is
stressful now it gets crazier enjoy the
freedom enjoy that freedom
[ __ ] don't think too much enjoy it and
have a good ass time damn I realize I
simply don't enjoy the freedom like
[Music]